on this episode we executed the single
best episode in askgaryvee history the
energy was just at week you see how it
ends
[Music]
you ask
huh
this is
Carrie B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 229 of
the askgaryvee show
five four five we did it we fought for
it it almost got ruined
with the last meeting Garrett but I'm
super pumped to bang out a five you know
what
and I said Garrett can you edit it can
you or whoever's editing it put a little
picture and run it in real time of when
Garrett was on episode 26 roof
that's your first no no this was a oh
you really wait a minute you and Garrett
are askgaryvee brother and sister Cece
I'm super excited
it's been a good week of shows feel like
like I feel like fresh I think that's
what happens sometimes and I think I'm
you know I love the word cadence I think
you know when you're doing it a lot you
get into similar answers and different
things I think it's opened up I've been
really impressed by the tremendous
answers that I'm just kidding
I've been very happy though with the
quality of the show and I hope you have
as well and your your comments are
absolutely oxygen for so many of you
that are starting to watch now the
engagement the comments means a lot to
me so thank you India let's get into
that show ward good morning Gary this is
warped from London with one question how
much of the success of vaynermedia do
you think is down to the brand Gary Vee
I think Gary Vee might be the best
content marketing strategy in history so
how much of the success of vaynermedia
is down to that what if Gary Vee the
brand was not there and what if Gary Vee
was just running vaynermedia without
producing any garrovick content out
there so thank you Ward I think the
answer is both you know I think I have
the luxury of proof being in the pudding
as a 22 year old in a five-year period I
grew a business from 3 to 65 million in
the old world no capital no real
internet at scale and so I'm proud that
if Gary Vaynerchuk CEO not out in the
ecosystem started vaynermedia 7 years
ago it you know it would be successful
in the truth is of course it would be
because really here's the punchline Ward
nobody in corporate America Pepsi
Campbell's the NHL none of our earliest
clients
[ __ ] about me and you know what 99% of
my clients don't now now that would be
naive to not understand that over the
half decade that I've been really
running the company first two years I
was somewhat above sales mentorship with
AJ and I was involved but I'm in full
pledge this is what I do for a living
now Gary Vee is my side hustle right I
think that there's been benefits you
know people walk in here I can think of
a brand we just won that they're just
the truth is it's because of the Gary
Vee stuff and so I think the answer is
both and I think that's what's really
cool you know I think one day people
realize how much I like to hedge and I
think of it as a hedge like both matter
they help each other ones they're if the
others not there it's kind of a little
bit of immigrant to me for somebody
who's so on the offense I have a lot of
conservativeness and practicality that
is the foundation of what I do and I
think brings a lot of value to a lot of
people watching if they can get through
the layers and so the answer is both
it's a really smart question I think
many people have done both play people
have done a lot of business on the back
of their brand when they entered it
right plenty of restaurants that are
named after famous there are millions of
things just clothing lines like that
unlimited and many people are just
unknown assassins met with a guy the
other days bill to four hundred million
dollar businesses and never heard of the
guy in my entire life nor have you you
can't even find anything about them and
and you know they have the humility and
the kind of personality that allows that
and so everything works not everything
works for you plenty people built huge
agencies not being known just operators
and there's been agencies built on the
backbone of you know individuals P
Diddy's agency is P Diddy and the great
people that he hired underneath but it
wouldn't have been there and so I'm
really feeling strong I'm feeling great
I feel like I'm really thing a stride
here a pre-prime of my career
I couldn't go fried because I got so
much to go let's go pre fried I like pre
prime for you you've got a lot baby
alright sorry okay
why hey Gary David and wide here from
Demi oh and we wanted to ask you a quick
question
is it challenging for you to make the
switch from selling to consumers with
wine to selling into large businesses
like Toyota or Mountain Dew and if so
how did you make the switch thanks Gary
uh it's been difficult because I like
selling to consumers a little bit more
and I did that and I'm selling the
company second so like in a weird way
even at the height of my career
financially power brand I'm doing
something that is in the short term a
decade which is long term for every one
of you watching which is one of the
fundamental reasons I will win more than
most of you because the level of
patience I have and humility to put in
the work is so much greater than you so
in the short term ten years I've decided
to do something I don't like as much
because it builds the platform for them
to allow me to do something that I love
the most and so this is the path I've
decided builds the best framework for me
to go out and sell to consumers again
one day and I've enjoyed and learned to
enjoy and found different nuances and
challenges in selling to b2b to big
companies but I definitely it's probably
the reason I've been so hot on the wine
stuff lately you know during my vacation
we had a lot of downtime when I was had
some downtime when the kids and family
went to go get the fruit stand and my
brain was getting crazy I want to do
some action I didn't go and like hit up
an executive to expand b2b work I
started looking at what Wine Library was
selling and tried to sell wine to people
right I still love the speed the speed
and in day-to-day interactions matter of
fact one things I just thinking about
for our team is that I think I want to
start a little shop I think we need to
sell stuff and I don't mean like just
garyvee t-shirts and stuff like that I
actually mean like cuz that's like
whatever I mean like something I think
we should brainstorm come up with
something and sell it yeah I think so
too cool
whoa
you
like a shop like a shop this shop has no
shot because AJ starting the foundation
and I trust AJ what happens is you
evolved is um and this is very much why
vaynermedia is important the level of
understanding that I have about the four
people in this room Dirac India Garrett
and dunk varies given how long they've
been around but boy is that the reason
I'm gonna be successful whereas in the
past I try to do business with other
people and they've been amazing and by
the way for Kyle and Lindsey and for all
the other characters I've jammed with
it's been my fault
I've over-promised and under-delivered
not happy for me I'm not excited but
what I learned was I don't have the
bandwidth like you know I thought I
could do everything I can't do
everything and so what you need to do is
have people that can do everything or a
lot and allow me to do magic on top of
it and look intermedium two years the
three million like yeah I sold those
clients but AJ knew how to farm it I can
do the hunting and then when I decided
to do everything and then three to one
hundred happens in RP right so I think
that that's what I'm looking for and I'm
trying to understand there's a lot of
people now I trust in here poof I can
open a lot of businesses but I want to
you know be smart about this and things
of that nature and so that's the
difference that's down to self-awareness
and delegation but realizing that you
can't be when you when you're an
entrepreneur you're the most optimistic
person on earth you can't deploy that
optimism against somebody else that's
driving and so what you need is context
and you need to be able to delegate to a
known entity within your ecosystem
investing allows me to bet on things
that I don't control I don't need to do
that with my own businesses anymore go
ahead
I can't hear this here we are hey Gary
random Slav ski here coming at you from
Pennsylvania and my question is I want
to interact with new and more positive
minded people using the power of social
media and how would I go about doing
that thank you so much I love your show
hope I can hear what you have to say
this is great what's his name ready I
heard it I heard Randy we're gonna do an
experiment here and tear up by the way I
don't I know other other Tyler under
Tyler get in here there there's a flaw
Stefan doesn't edit anymore but you know
what get Stefan to Stefan by the way
Stefan's new haircut is legit like like
Stefan looks way better goody -
everybody's been upgrading their hair
game you look good man I'm proud of it
even though you're not editing anymore
I'm making this statement because you
made the flaw you've made the flaw even
and you love to think you're perfect you
rock other Tyler you've made the flaw
the amount of times on this show that
I've said to link that [ __ ] up and then
we don't is unacceptable you're done
with it so you can go back to your thing
though you might get called back in if
I'm asking for something to be linked up
it's gotta be linked up
alright so cool that's it so like right
now when I link up what's his name again
Randy I'm gonna link up Randy we're
gonna link his Twitter account in
YouTube and Facebook and I know some
people different did copy and get it but
we can also flash his handles we're
gonna flash his handles here at least
his Twitter
and here's what's gonna happen the
amount anybody who's been watching this
show for a hundred to 200 episodes is a
positive and like-minded person we've
got the community for you Randy instead
of going to use something philosophical
I'm going to give you something
practical vaynernation if you think
you're an awesome person and your big
ideas and you love networking I want you
to reach out to Randy and I don't mean
just tweet and be like hey I mean reach
out to him give him your number
like email like connect Randy you're
gonna have the 500 people that are gonna
do it 17 is gonna be a real thing and
there you go man 17 like-minded positive
people for you you like that
let's go let's go last one
Gus garyvee thank you for taking this
question man your friend Gus Fernandez
from Orlando Florida appreciate it big
fan here's my question the
Entrepreneurship Hall of Fame just
called you're getting inducted man in
2025 but they need to know what the
plaque is gonna read let us know which
hat are you anywhere are you gonna have
the hat says CEO NFL owner what let us
know man you're the man thanks Gus
it would it would be a picture with a
bee on it my hat would have a bee on it
and it would say honey Emperor I want to
build a honey Empire I want to be known
as an entrepreneur 20 30 40 years from
now that this was the guy that came
along and he built a trillion-dollar
empire on the way he interacted with his
people he created a true insular you
know it's funny so once in a while when
people first kind of meet me they're
like like and for really in a good way
they're like building a cult you know
like they're like they're like razzing
me a little bit but they're actually
weirdly like like I just really love
leadership I really love people winning
not at I love winning and I just
genuinely believe that I can win and you
can win and like we all have different
ambitions and therefore wants and if one
wants to go and then go do their thing
Mazel Tov go do it go win like [ __ ] do
you know interesting it would be for me
if somebody left here if Garrett left
here and created G squared media and it
started beating vaynermedia be like my
god kudos [ __ ] I want to kill him but
like you know like kudos like have
nothing but respect for the game honey
Empire I'm going to like this is what
I've always had difficulty with how much
Steve Jobs has been put on a pedestal
cool you invented awesome [ __ ] but
extracting value out of people by making
them cry and pushing them to that place
it's just Star Wars [ __ ] like like you
know like you know the force is slightly
better than the dark side just slightly
and that I'm fascinated by and I want to
build something I mean that's what do
you think this is about like what do you
think this is about it's about the woman
I just met in the lobby
who works in this new building that
stopped me and said I work here I'm
sorry to grab you like like like I found
out about you everybody that's working
here he's been talking about your videos
I watched it I'm inspired to do my own
thing
I can make money I can get Fame and a
lot I couldn't do the TV show like five
I could have been on Top Chef back in
the wine day it was number one [ __ ]
show on TV I could mean famous then I
did way more famous than I am right now
eight years later legacy changing the
game like creating the framework for so
many of you out there to look up to and
aspire to to build your honey Empire so
that good can win cuz that's good
that's just good for all of us honey
we're just gonna sell honey right if you
own a honey farm let us know because
I'll JV and we'll like baby with our
first product should be honey you might
be India that was a good I think we're
just gonna sell honey on Shopify just
like honey I do you think we can do a
million Rev the first year I think we
can wait a minute you know what's really
crazy if this was like a sitcom I would
love the next scene to be like literally
like it's a twenty eight Milic like I
feel like I feel like if there's a by
the way you want to talk about a good
piece of content for Facebook or
whatever it is in four years this clip
with the interview I do with Fast
Company explaining how we why and how we
built a 50 million dollar honey company
by the way I'm actually dead serious I'm
gonna do it I'm in India it's on you
actually is your parallel saga and you
to dunk you love this kind of crap yeah
we didn't do the porn shop because
stunwin failed dunker on it too I want
to put two people's pressure we're
starting a honey company question of the
day if you had to sell something and
start a company a physical thing
what kind of company would it be and
what would be the name have the greatest
weekend ever I'm taking my kids garage
nailing tomorrow the hustle starts early
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering
[Music]
ah
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]